walk him to this video I'm playing
international master ha gap from Spain
he will play b6 now no he always plays
b6 not yet ok so ready I made a
conscious decision and to play an
opening that I know some stuff about
simply because of my general bed form
hoping that you know in one of my main
opening sound at least not get into time
travel ok we have a form of the ready
system that um that is quite often
played by teammates of mine or former
teammates of mine we did lots of work on
this and we we have played the structure
numerous times in blitz chess in in
tournament chess all kinds of situations
and it feels like white is enjoying
quite good a good structure we usually
call it the logging off sister I'm named
after the the Grandmaster but are we
looking off a grandmaster from whose
biggest on if i'm not mistaken thank you
from whose biggest on the main point is
that why it is having an extra bone in
the center the e4 pawn and black a
suffering a bit from lack of space ok
wait h3 he might take and play Bishop g3
and okay that's not enough
that's really not enough okay he's got
94 as a possible counterplay so I'm play
rock d 1 preparing the retreat if
necessary I can always expel the night
with be three after that and my general
idea here is to play an F for FY d 5
setting up a steamroller in the center
yeah it's sometimes nice to have a
position on the board that you actually
no it's um it's helpful in terms of time
management mostly let's get get this
away oh I didn't even see that moose
it's also questionable if I take a three
Bishop a three-night be five hmm ok I
should I should just play it I mean it's
it's clear that i will play it anyway I
don't need to calculate it till the end
Queen a five and I just take it I guess
now I'm I have a very nice control in
this position should i go F for I guess
so I cannot pin the night this is a
constant worry with the the bishops
being on the board this is why I'm
relatively quickly went for the trade
the bishop trade okay if I go f5 he has
95 I don't I don't want that necessarily
okay let's plan strengthening move
I don't I don't need to play you five
immediately I can prepared a bit more
look everyone for example supporting the
upon maybe 595 and f5 ism is a move yeah
it's got night before then okay
if I've you will a four is not not
terrible I have no good square for the
night ringing I'd like to play your five
without without him being able to play
95 maybe I need to reroute like 93 and
then e5 this is mainly a good idea 93
and Danny 5 so that after night moves I
have 94 and 96 I don't want to trade I
don't want to trade him yes this is good
this is good I need to play 85 and 90
for this is the improvement here we go
here you cannot cannot even now this I
overlooked I really overlook that this
is stupid ready to overlook that okay
it's still a good position but I really
should have seen that now g4 fails due
to Queen a form but g4 in general is as
good so that I fight for the foursquare
let's get ahead here a Quincy five
really was so bad walls allowing this
with temple 96 now I can I can first
secure the spawn
so night and 96 anyway come on yeah this
is should fall apart now ready Knight f6
or 96 again either something better what
about e6e six queen geez haven't made
yeah yeah that's that's immediately
crushing rock cakes I take on this
heaven okay checkmate yeah that the idea
was that if he takes here i hope that i
could i calculate it is correctly yes I
did takes on d7 this is the point rook
takes rook takes and it's it's this this
coming ok yes B should be six but rooty
one again supporting the pawn yeah dad
sometimes helpful to just play something
you know so that you don't have to
reinvent the wheel all the time now this
is this was I think a nice a nice
maneuver maybe it maybe the computer
wants to play this immediately because
it says that yeah tactics tactics
tactics i have this one yeah this is
good for white this is also good for
white not huh okay but positional leave
I like this move it's a good strategical
decision and
because i get i get my desire pawn
structure and it's this is really
running into this stuff yeah why does in
complete control and and winning now
yeah this is a in fact this type of reti
opening is quite quite nice for it it's
um a good long-term strategic position
where you can make make progress slowly
black has relatively little counter
flame may be here after this is actually
a good idea maybe c5 here and then
Bishop to c6 yeah yeah this is maybe
what you should have done all right okay
thanks for watching